my father was a great hero so they say  sometimes the world doesn't need another  hero sometimes what it needs is a  monster  my prince I've missed you something  troubles you the Sultan is preparing for  battle  it requires 1,000 boys for his army  including your son under your mother  look away you can't protect us I'll find  a way I have been waiting an eternity  for a man of your strength to arrive  welcome to your life what is it you are  seeking I want the power to destroy my  enemies and save my family  drink Dracula welcome to your life  what's happening to you  and the thing men fear not a cost  something else  I see the devil inside him  do you think you are alive because you  can fight  you're alive because of what I did to  save you  so uh never forget who I am